[Music]
it's just after sunrise and
sixteen-year-old mori bantul is already
hard at work
practicing drills with his longsword
Bancho
is an ambitious samurai in training and
today he must impress his teachers more
than ever today he'll make his request
to travel to the capital city of Edo for
a year of marshal scholarly studies and
he needs their support along with his
father's the year is 1800 in the castle
town of Kochi capital of the Tosa domain
in Japan the daimyo rules the domain and
about 1,500 samurai retainers serve him
for 200 years Japan has been a peace and
the samurai once primarily warriors now
play a much wider range of roles they
are also government officials scholars
teachers and even masters of the tea
ceremony or artists to prepare for these
diverse responsibilities young samurai
like Van Shiro studied the twin paths of
literary learning and the martial arts
at 15 he went through the rites of
adulthood and received the dice show a
pair of swords the longsword is for
training in combat while the short sword
has a soul solemn purpose to commit
ritual suicide or seppuku
if he dishonours himself his family or
the daimyo Pantera idealizes the
legendary samurai Miyamoto Musashi a
renowned swordsman who lived a hundred
and fifty years earlier but banjaara
doesn't admire his swordsmanship alone
Miyamoto Musashi was also a master
calligrapher and painter that's the real
reason and Cheryl wants to go to edit he
secretly wants to be a painter too
after finishing his practice at home he
bids his father goodbye and walks to
school his father is preparing to
accompany the daimyo to the capital the
Tokugawa Shogun head of the Japanese
military government requires all the
regional rulers to alternate years
between their castle town in the home
domain and the capital city the costly
tracks back and forth keep the daimyo
subordinate and prevent them from
building up their own military forces to
challenge the Shogunate the daimyo his
wife and children live in the capital
full-time where they serve as hostages
to ensure his loyalty but the practice
doesn't just affect the daimyo it
determines much of the rhythm of life in
Japan samurai must accompany the daimyo
to Edo this year it's been Shiraz
father's turned to go and ban Shiro is
desperate to go with him but given that
he's still in training
he'll need permission from both his
father and the domain at school and
Shiraz first lesson is in sword fighting
under his teachers Stern eye he pairs up
with his classmates and goes through the
routines
he's been practicing at the end of the
lesson he reminds the instructor of his
request to go to Edo
the instructor cracks his first smile of
the day and banter all feels confident
he will gain his support next bench ro
practices archery horsemanship and
swimming before his academic courses in
the afternoon courses cover Confucian
philosophy morality and history when the
instructor calls on him he has the
response on the tip of his tongue
ensuring another supporter for his
campaign by the end of the day and Shiro
feels confident that his formal request
will be approved but the greatest
challenge is still ahead of him
convincing his father his father
believes that martial arts are more
important than the literary arts so ban
Shiro doesn't mention his artistic
ambitions
instead he talks about renowned sword
instructors he can
and teaching certifications he can earn
to improve his professional prospects
back in Kochi then he makes his final
strongest argument if he goes this time
and succeeds his father can retire and
send him instead in the future it's this
last point that finally sells him and
Shiro's father agrees to take him on his
tour of duty in the bustle of the
capital city bank ro will finally have
the opportunity to pursue his secret
ambition to become a painter travel a
hundred and fifty years further back in
time and join forces with another group
of elite and formidable warriors the
cossacks or expand your knowledge of
japanese culture with this video on
kabuki dance drama
[Music]